[Musique]
bienvenue dans passe dans un nouveau
numéro avec beaucoup de sujets qui vous
concerne et qui vous passionne et pour
en parler des gens que vous aimez ce
sont les mères avec à néry mouffard vous
êtes la mère de chevreuse mais à l'ère
de cheuvreux c'est vrai que je disais
c'est la fonction politique qui a encore
sauvé sauvegardés par les français
effectivement effectivement on est un
peu épargné
alors il ya une profession qui l'avions
aime beaucoup si les avocats quand ils
ont besoin
vincent aux annéciens soit vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris
bonsoir oui je suis pas sûr que ce soit
la profession préféré des français - on
peut en parler ça peut être un débat
mais la possession je pensais depuis sa
cellule c'est encore mieux puissiez mais
on est sur la bonne voie je pense plus à
rejoindre et vous êtes donc avocat au
barreau de paris et spécialiste de la
liberté d'expression vous avez publié il
ya quelques mois un coq de la liberté
d'expression qui rend compte de toutes
les textes qui ce qui concerne ce sujet
vaste qui a vocation à devenir obsolète
rapidement vu le oui de la propension
qu'a d'autres pays à faire des textes
divers des textes paraît seulement
philippe brillault bonsoir d'être le
maire du chesnay robbins jeu médecin
vous êtes médecin urgentiste cas voilà
oui c'est vrai mais et à s'assurer les
professions alors évidemment urgentistes
en plus un oui j'aime bien ce qui est
rapide ouais ce qui est rapide et est ce
que justement peut-être que la
profession de maintenant la fonction de
maire est une des fonctions politiques
où on voit un peu ce qu'on fait
sinon les résultats observations
diagnostic traitement et donc vous êtes
le maire de disney au concours puisqu'il
faut dire maintenant chez des recours
puisque vous êtes mariés
le génie c'est vrai je suis également ma
vie privée
joe femmes la janis vous êtes éditeur
voilà toujours et peut-être aux fins
d'émission vous présenterez ce dernier
s'appelle beaulieu est conquis
chef-d'oeuvre un petit chef-d'oeuvre
c'est entre léo malet san antonio non
franchement c'est extra c'est d'ailleurs
très copieux drôle
il ya du fond ces banlieues restent mais
ça pour être banlieue ouest
oui c'est mieux ici que ça ce n'est pas
bien donc vendu un ça va
oui pour lui c'est pas très joli mais
bon ne savent plus musical on dit
parfois je cdc la banlieue de nom vous
aimez ça risque et pauline on a été pris
des péquenots à une certaine époque
parce qu'on était à la campagne
c'était un excès d oise la seine et oise
seine et oise qui on est devenus
banlieue ouest ça nous a un peu fait ça
donnait un peu des tofs j'ai vu ce que
ça vient de lieux banny dont c'est ça tu
prends le soin l'origine oui alors on va
parler le premier sujet c'est le sujet
qui divise depuis des années on va se
demander pourquoi peut-être les les
français c'est l'événement d'ailleurs
cela va être dans de cette émission
c'est le la question du voile alors je
disais événement parce que c'est vrai
que depuis
depuis une vingtaine d'années quand même
maintenant les premières étudiante
enfin les premières lycéenne dans le
dans le lycée possession avoir fait tant
que tu es le 30 ans 30 ans 30 ans et ça
fait 30 ans je viens d'avoir fait une
émission là dessus c'est ça une
trentaine d'années un savoureux génie
parfois les hip hop b et lors la
question et a ressurgi après après une
altercation entre un élu du
rassemblement national et une une femme
voilée qui étaient dans le public et
tout le monde prend part à ces débats
avec des positions très tranchées on a
l'impression que ou trois pas de
solution qui satisfasse tout le monde le
sud non en oui c'est compliqué je pense
que le sujet a pas vraiment surgit là
ces dernières semaines puisqu'on avait
eu à quelques mois décathlon qui avait
un peu défrayé la chronique aussi avec
[Musique]
je suis premier régulièrement supprimé
je crois un peu suite à la bronca
oui bien sûr côté cadeaux étaient
obligés de ce sujet là et quand même un
petit peu le serpent de mer maintenant
depuis depuis trois quatre ans et on
voit qu'on est tous assez inconfortable
parce que parce qu'on n'a pas de réponse
on n'a pas de réponses claires et
précises on a une opinion
enfin on a une manière de le vivre
intérieurement geek et pas forcément
sereine et apaisée
c'est une vraie question la loi
aujourd'hui n'importe pas de réponse
enfin n'apporte pas de réponse peut-être
suffisamment clair vous préciserez mais
c'est vrai que c'est très inconfortable
c'est très inconfortable parce que on a
en a les textes on à le vivre ensemble
qui aujourd'hui est vraiment altéré et
puis après on allait les réels serait
pourquoi pas paru dans la réaction par
le port lui-même de vol alors je pense
qu'il ya eu d'abord ces réactions enfin
ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé ce qui est ce qui a
fait la une des médias la semaine
dernière c'est moi ça me fait réagir de
manière complètement épidermique c'est
de la provocation pure et simple c'est
la provocation pure et simple ça je
construis tout le monde sera d'accord
qu'elle se soit notre position sur le
web pour donner cette sortie maintenant
on voit bien que en tout cas en ce qui
concerne l'école en ce qui concerne ces
fameuses sorties scolaires face on est
on est dans un flou dans un entre deux
eaux qui laisse tout le monde dans une
situation inconfortable et et en
fonction de notre positionnement
politique notre parole va aussi avoir un
écho qui va être plus ou moins fort
j'ai entendu d'une terre il ya quelques
jours avoir un discours qui était très
apaisant alors je suis très à l'aise de
reprendre les propos de suite
jean-michel blanquer
d'ailleurs ces bassesses sais même pas
ce que c'est miss d'egypte
oui marc pilliot gros c'est pas parce
que la loi des quelque chose qu'on dise
qu'on est obligé de dire que ça ne pose
pas problème pour eux ce soir que je
crois qu'on s'offre aujourd'hui de cette
difficulté à vivre ensemble et on
n'arrive pas apporté de solution qui
nous rendre les choses plus faciles pour
bien vivre ensemble et c'est vraiment en
tout cas dans notre quotidien de mersch
parce que vous en conviendrez c'est
vraiment notre mission numéro c'est
faire en sorte que les habitants de nos
de nos communes et villages vivent vivre
ensemble sereinement de manière apaisée
et là on est face à une situation dans
laquelle on n'a pas trop de réponse
légale et pas trop de moyens d'agir sans
attiser finalement c'est extra c'est
peut-être juste quelque chose de
juridique parce que c'est interdit le
voile pendant une sortie pendant cet
interdit à l'école d'accord la loi
l'interdît qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
sortie scolaire si ce n'est un cours
délocalisés
donc si c'est un cours délocalisés il
n'ya pas avoir de voile quand on est
donc en cours
donc ça me paraît en tout cas une piste
intéressante donc 18 heures tout le
monde je ne fais pas ça aberrant que
quelqu'un dise bah voilà est-ce que
cette dame pour l enlever son voile
presse que c'est humiliant pas humiliant
comment encore puisqu'il y provoquant je
dirais la un voile et c'est très bien
c'est radiner c'est endemol en fait un
problème particulier devant tout le
monde et c'est ça oui mais devant tout
le monde tient moment là il faut il faut
bien à un moment dire les choses parce
que c'est quand même c'est comme dans
une assemblée si c'est tout à fait ce
que nous partageons en aucun moment le à
aucun moment la moindre des positions du
rassemblement national
mais franchement ça me paraît pas
aberrant qu'un élu dise voilà est-ce que
c'est la place d'une femme voilée un
compagnon de voyage ça ne me choque pas
après chacun pour sa réponse
c'était très bien qu'après 10 ans de 10
la loi ne l'interdît pas ok c'est un
truc mais poser la question ça me paraît
pas aberrant
on parle de l'aspect juridique avant
mais comme vous dit et c'est vrai que
les maires sont confrontés à ça philippe
brillault c'est vrai que c'est une
question que je vois depuis quelques
mois au niveau du voile ah oui oui nous
passions je sens que j'ai entendues
alors la commune tient on en voit de
plus en plus mais c'est quoi ces dévoile
bon en fait on a des femmes qui ont
comme religion islam et qui par respect
mais t'as foulard on peut très bien
avoir un foulard qui respecte et qui
n'est pas d'une volonté de stigmatiser
ou provoquer ou d'affichés et moi ça
quelque part je respecte mais lorsqu'on
a vraiment quelque part un signe
extérieur qu'on peut considérer comme
une volonté d'affirmation de provocation
va effectivement on s'interroge mais
avant de paille du vol aurait pu parler
des cantines avec des demandes de repas
de la gestion de la piscine
non mes excuses verse et que depuis
quelques années on voit progressivement
demander un certain nombre de signes en
rapport quelque part avec un affichage
volontaire d'une religion qui veut
rentrer dans notre dans nos villes en
imposant quelque part quelque chose et
c'est là où quelque part nous nous
interrogeons je m'interroge pour
l'instant il n'est pas question de
stigmatiser de / ce que me dit ma
collègue
notre rôle c'est d'essayer d'assurer je
dirais une unité dans une commune par
contre si certains mais ça peut être le
voile comme un gosse qui est aussi
indépendamment de sa va mettre le bazar
ode à quel moment nous avons le devoir
de dire attention on va provoquer
quelque part des troubles dans la
commune s'il ya trouble
je pense que nous devons utiliser les
lois qui existent
il ya des lois utiliser long faut les
utiliser
est-ce qu'il faut inventer autre chose
je pense que on a suffisamment les
outils pour le faire partout et puis une
autre loi on sait pas comment pourrait
l'expliquer mais et la loi moi je disais
la loi elvis le rapport de gérard
larcher la suite
une interview avec bruno jeudy jeu
intéressant et bien oui c'est vrai et le
présent la république nous a dit qu'il
allait en parler je pense que c'est
important qu'ils affirment
cette identité française et qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent de plus cela parce que
derrière bien évidemment on va décliner
l'immigration va on décline le tout et
c'est là où il ya un danger
donc je dis attention soyons prudents et
regardons les choses avec les outils que
nous avons en tout cas moi pour
l'instant c'est plutôt une vigilance une
prudence mais peut-être une fermeté
aussi pour dire là on n'est pas d'accord
il là on est d'accord et et clarifier la
position de ce que ce qu'est la position
française c'est vrai que vous notant un
peu que le président s'exprime
oui moi j'attends que j'attends
effectivement qui s'exprime on
administre d'éducation nationale qui a
pris moins de 10 sur extrêmement clair
alors on y va diviser la majorité oui
alors il ya des il ya des gens dans la
majorité qui sont bien d'accord les
listes à côté je pense qu'on a besoin de
gens aujourd'hui qui nous aident à
garder tous bords confondus pour
garantir cette unité républicaine de
notre pays la france
voilà c'est tout vincent warin étions
alors sur le plan juridique déjà où est
ce qu'on a c'est un problème politique
du jeu et je pense que ce dont il faut
partir c'est du fait que un système
juridique n'est que le reflet en tout
cas dans une démocratie de la volonté
des personnes d'organiser la société
d'une certaine manière est donc pour moi
la première question que je pose c at-on
le droit d'avoir un avis une opinion une
volonté d'organiser la société dans
laquelle on vit d'une certaine manière
ça c'est une première chose en ce qui me
concerne je pense que la réponse est oui
une fois qu'on a posé ce principe là
beaucoup de choses en découlent
les textes des libertés mais aussi des
interdictions il y en a plein d
interdiction on peut pas se trimballer
par exemple dans la rue sans vêtements
on pourrait très bien pensé que
vous êtes promenés la nature dans
l'éprouvette proche de la nature est là
mais il se trouve que la société des
gens qui sont devenus peut-être que dans
cinquante ans de pouvoir
aujourd'hui on peut pas pour plein de
raisons on estime que c'est indécent que
les enfants terre peu importe donc donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que il faut
accepter que chacun une vision politique
des choses et puisse avoir une opinion
sur la sauce sur la manière dont la
société est régie ça c'est le premier
point
parce que bien évidemment si chacun des
sujets auxquels on est confrontés se
résout par une question binaire ai je le
droit ou pas on va pas aller très loin
donc une fois qu'on a posés çà il ya
effectivement quelques textes
fondamentaux qui sont très importants et
alors le texte fondateur c'est la
constitution et dans son article 1er la
constitution après donc le préambule dit
la chose suivante la france la france
est une république indivisible laïque
etc
il n'y a pas d'explication qu'est ce que
la france puisque le hic est ce que la
république on regarde la république
donc voilà tout part de là donc déjà
rien que ça c'est sujet à interprétation
ne parlons pas de laïcité mais
simplement voilà c'est donc donc rien
que cette phrase-là peut prêter à
interprétation
et cette interprétation et les
politiques elle est sociale elle dépend
des gens qui vivent dans une société à
un moment donné voilà donc le débat pour
moi n'est pas une question de droit de
3,2 et voilà c'est un débat politique
c'est vrai qu'à la loi de 1905 c'est
vrai qu'il ya de quoi pleurer dont
capcom comme on est dans une république
laïque et et je tiens aussi à ajouter
que la constitution bien évidemment
nomme aussi par ailleurs l'état avec un
grand e
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose et à
la république et à l'état
faut pas confondre voilà et puis en plus
de la constitution mais il
une loi de 1905 qui est une loi et
beaucoup d'autres textes et notamment
sur le sujet très revient apparemment
régulièrement sur les accompagnateurs
etc il ya une loi de 2004 qui a réglé le
problème des signes ostentatoires de des
étudiants par ailleurs il ya un principe
qui est dans à la fois la constitution
et puis surtout dans beaucoup de textes
de loi sur la neutralité du service
public et en particulier à l'école les
enseignants mais il ya une circulaire
ensuite de 2004 d'applications qui
explique qu'il vient préciser que ce
texte est ce ce devoir de cette
obligation de ne pas afficher de signes
ostentatoires s'appliquer non seulement
dans l'enceinte de l'école mais
également dans les sorties scolaires
sportives et des draps et ça ça concerne
les étudiants et dans leur grande
sagacité
les rédacteurs de cette circulaire on
ajouté dans un autre article
la loi ne concerne pas les parents
d'élèves mais je ne suis pas sûr que
quand ils ont écrit cela ils pensaient
donc s'articuler remet en aucun cas des
parents c'est les parents d'élèves qui
vont attendre leurs enfants la santé de
l'école sortie de crise même qui vont
participer à un conseil de classe
voilà donc pour revenir bardot rovio
voilà la question du voile parce qu'il
pleut questure il ya une question il ya
des gens qui vous fait une question
religieuse mais il ya aussi une question
sur les droits de la femme sur le statut
de la femme
non c'est important sinon des signes le
dessine l'image que sa montre et quand
on vous dit qu'on vous dit voilà on a le
droit de vouloir vivre dans une
république et avec les principes c'est
un peu ça vous dit souci non sa pause de
six probable moi ça me parle crûment
contradictoire avec l'idée que je me
fais d'une
statut de la femme en règle générale
voilà c'est après c'est une sorte de
choc culturel
un choix de société chacun est bien
évidemment libre de faire celui qu'il
estime être le bon mais moi j'estime que
ce n'est pas le mien voilà donc on
résume mon rêve n'est pas de voir des
femmes voilées
mon rêve n'est pas de voir une femme se
cacher mon rêve n'est pas de voir des
femmes qui pensent que tous les hommes
sont des porcs et qu'on va le lui a
sauté dessus cette fois ci s'est
activement sa majo par la nuit des
étudiantes et notamment des quelques
unes qui sont voilées je veux dire on
n'est pas d'accord mais on en discute de
façon tout à fait si vide mais c'est pas
du tout ma vision de la société donc
quand vous ils se moquent ça pose un
problème du vivre ensemble c'est aussi
parce que en france il ya ce débat là
mais j'ai l'impression que tous les
débats comme ça aujourd'hui très
sensible j'ai position d'affirmer on est
obligé de dire des choses très fort très
durs les uns contre les autres il ya un
déchirement quand même de la société sur
tous ces débats qui est un peu
inquiétant tout à fait et puis je pense
que quand on en essayant d'apporter des
réponses à ce débat ou des pistes en
tout cas de réflexion si on a un
positionnement politique au sens de la
politique partisane nécessairement
nous proposerons interprété d'une
manière ou d'une autre je reviens à un
sujet qui a animé les débats il ya
quelques années qui était le mariage
pour tous rappelez-vous du sujet du
mariage pour tous c'est fini vous avez
été particulièrement engagée sur ce
sujet là si on était contre la bombe
pour tous vous le dire rires apple pour
pour les si on était contre la filiation
principalement mais voilà si on était
contre le mariage pour tous très
nécessaire très rapidement on était
assimilé à homophobes etc
il y avait cette sorte de
cristallisation qui se délient mais il
ya eu des dérives bien évidemment mais
les dérives étaient minoritaires
or on s'est très rapidement fait on
arrête très rapidement été assimilés
jeudi on parce que je m'associe 1 à ce
jour est très rapidement été assimilée à
homophobes et itar ce qui fait qu'à un
moment c'est vraiment retiré deux des
bars en se disant que ça devenait
inaudible c'était n'était plus audible
aujourd'hui très simplement quelqu'un de
droite va vous dire moi je suis pas le
voile c'est pas mon idéal de société je
n'ai pas envie de voir de femmes voilées
dans l'espace public et en même temps
que je me dis que celle que je vois dans
l'espace public finalement aux se
montrait et qu'elle cache certainement
encore un plus grand nombre qui reste
enfermée chez elle et qui sont peut-être
des situations encore plus encore plus
dramatique pour la pour la position de
la femme
je me dis que si moi en tant que est
étiqueté lrg seugé ce discours là on va
me dire que j'ai un positionnement qui
est radicale et que je apparente aux
positions du front national ce que je ce
que je combats tous les jours vous voyez
donc c'est très compliqué d'apporter une
réponse avec impatience les sur un sujet
comme qui est sensible vous avez vu
comment on fait attention à ce qu'on dit
oui tous les cas là je viens en temps
d'un avocat et ça m'intéresse parce que
j'ai jamais autant d'appels d'avocat
depuis deux ans sur tous les dossiers
qu'on peut avoir tellement à drocourt
est tant mieux donc vraiment je pense
que vous êtes amitié cac avait de
l'avenir contrairement à ce que vous
avez du tout
mais vous avez dit quelque chose
d'important ces politiques
donc c'est politique c'est à dire que
sur les responsables politiques qui
doivent prendre des décisions
or les décisions nous pouvons être
amenés à prendre peuvent être contestées
dans l'eure la minutes qui suivent var a
référé un tribunal les réseaux sociaux
et tout est là on a aussi besoin d'un
avocat pour défendre et nous avons pas
parlé de la justice parce qu'à un moment
ou un autre
tout ce que nous pouvons être va
considérer amené à faire parce qu elles
nous paraissent légales vont être mis au
tribunal et là on peut avoir des
jurisprudences des condamnations des
appels aux autres et c'est là où
j'aurais tendance à dire nous les
politiques on est quand même un certain
nombre à avoir le courage de faire il ya
des femmes extrêmement courageuse des
hommes un peu aussi peut-être moins que
les femmes mais il y en a quelques uns
quand même vous savez on aaron hill ya
un terme qui base d'un organe génital
masculin je sais pas trop il faut être
connu donc ça veut dire que dès que vous
prenez des décisions il faut faire
attention
et donc c'est aussi un obstacle au
maintien des règles et de la cohésion de
notre société aujourd'hui parce que nous
débouchons obligatoirement vers des
sujets qui peuvent s'appeler le
communautarisme je crois qu'il faut
qu'on ose parler des choses et on en est
arrivé là
le voile c'est quelque chose qui cache
non pas une partie du visage de la tête
mais qui cachent beaucoup plus que ça et
aujourd'hui le débat il est là et je
pense qu'il faut qu'on ait le courage je
dirais mais intelligent dans le sens de
la cohésion le général d'en parler parce
que si on n'en parle pas et si on n'ose
pas et bien effectivement dans quelques
mois on sera pas surpris des résultats
dans les urnes et quand vous dites
en effet parce qu'il ya eu des décisions
de mer souvient des éditions sur par
exemple interdisant les burqini
dans l'est dans les piscines oui qui ont
été censurés par le conseil d'état nous
demander la piscine ne sort uniquement
pour les femmes
oui oui non mais c est donc et donc
pardon excusez moi et donc c'est vrai
que la politique peut être censuré par
la justice comme comuzzi bon moi je
demande que notre avocat nous défendez
est ce que oui mais est-ce que ça
revient pas à ce qu'il disait tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu' il faudrait un
moment une position politique claire qui
entraînerait le droit derrière dsk des
positions claires de justice maintenant
minutes et position politique claire
martine aubry s'est clairement à la
mairie de lille s'était clairement
déclarés pour les piscines pour décoder
des espaces étaient moment réservée aux
femmes
accédant vous demande vient nourrir les
plus saugrenues donc ça c'est des
opinions non plus sa décision précitée
des payants mais ces jeunes 200 jours
sont utiles à kankan vin chaud et des
sciences dit c'est une décision
politique on a le droit de vivre on a le
droit de pouvoir vouloir vivre dans
telle ou telle société
ça c'est de la politique mais non mais
et est ce qu est ce qu il faudrait pas
est ce que c'est ça qui part qui est pas
au foot ici peut naître que personne ne
sait dans quelle société on est dans une
société de l'immédiateté où il faut
prendre un texte immédiatement pour
croire que on résout un problème ça pose
en réalité les textes sont le fruit
normalement 2 2 d'un cheminement
sociétal d'une réflexion etc et d'un
cheminement politique aussi et donc il
faut comprendre en fait et donc
expliquer aussi quand on est politique
expliquer quels sont les fondements des
décisions qu'on prend
parce que sinon en fait on est on vous
on vous sert comme argument facile à
longueur de temps
les thermes stigmatisation intolérance
moi je ne sais pas ce que c'est que la
tolérance et l'intolérance en tant que
avocats hommes de loi je ne sais pas ce
que c'est je sais ce que c'est que les
qualités humaines je sais qu'il a monté
la méchanceté l'empathie la tolérance il
ya beaucoup de choses donc je joue en
tant que juriste la tolérance je ne sais
pas ce que c'est et d'une certaine
manière ça m'intéresse pas sauf les
maisons queue leu leu
le projet de doute le projet politique
m'intéresse le droit intéresse le
conseil d'état a rendu un avis en 2013
pardon de mais parce que je trouvais ça
intéressant
en 2013 il a rendu un avis à la demande
du défenseur des droits et notamment
dans cette selon avi il explique
pourquoi il est nécessaire pour les le
service public d'adopter neutralité
religieuse c'est font comprendre
pourquoi on pourrait à la limite aussi
souhaité une société dans laquelle on
n'a pas besoin de neutralité rien d une
vérité absolue
pourquoi et le vélo saxon qui sont allés
à dubaï dit est dit la chose suivante
pour assurer le respect de la de la
liberté de conscience de l'usager l'état
est responsable et garant
c'est dans les tailles de conscience de
la liberté de conscience et donc dans
cette réponse là ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que lorsque vous avez des
signes ostentatoires religieux
de quelle que nature que ce soit voile
ou autres kippa ou autres qu'on soit
bien clair là dessus dans des portés par
des fonctionnaires est bien c'est de
nature à empêcher ou à limiter ou à
faire une pression sur les libertés de
conscience des usagers
j'ai vu la faible rennais appliquant ce
principe qui me semble absolument claire
appliquons ce principe est donc
effectivement dans une sortie scolaire a
fortiori quand on a des enfants qui sont
encore plus belle et j'allais dire
malléable sujet à pression et c est qu
on les accompagne dans le cadre d'un
d'une sortie scolaire il me semble
relever de la simple évidence du bon
sens que les personnes qui sont donc en
charge d accompagner donc qui ont
l'autorité il a vite ces enfants là où
désagrégation de l'autorité mais mais de
toute façon ils autorisaient parce
qu'ils sont adultes et il accompagne
dans le cas d'une sortie scolaire que la
moindre des choses c'est qu'ils ne
manifestent aucun signe particulier
ostentatoires religieux de quelque
nature que ce soit sur le dossier
planté vrai moi je vais poser une
question notre avocat est ce qu'il
serait prêt à défendre a recours que
nous serions sur une ouverture
spécifique d'une piscine aux femmes
à la demande de la communauté est-ce que
vous défendriez et qu'est ce que vous
feriez pour la défense alors voulait
ouvrir la piscine ça non il faudrait pas
avoir à parler il ajouté comprenez pas
votre position vous aimez c'est une
provocation alors là c est la position
contraire est contré sur il me semble
que c'est pas une fausse réponse mais ça
il ya des spécialités endroits et
notamment aimerait que ce genre monsieur
semble ici et il me semble que ce genre
de problématique se sent pas élevé du
sud le premier ministre hâtif s'appelle
est ravalé me balader le droit non
satisfait est donc malheureusement ça
sort totalement mon champ de compétence
ça je ne sais quand tu ne suis pas un
publi serait l'idéal
c'est donc en principe bien sûr que je
l'aurais fait je l'aurais fait c'est
simplement pas comme l'a rappelé le
maire du chesnay rocancourt l'ensemble
de nos décisions qu'elle porte sur des
faits de société comme qu'on me parlait
du voile à lille avec les piscines
quelle que soit la matière d'urbanisme
ans quelle que soit l'ensemble de nos
décisions sont de plus en plus sujet à
des recours recours la plupart du temps
devant le tribunal administratif est en
tout cas moi c'est un sentiment j'ai
peut-être un peu on peut échanger là
dessus j'ai de plus en plus l'impression
qu'on est finalement déposséder de notre
pouvoir de décision aux profils au
profit du juge
on prend une décision elle est contestée
qui va trancher
le gt judiciariser voilà que de toute
façon et c'est vrai les verts / de plus
en plus qu'aux français
la décision que je sais que je manque le
exacte doit faire l'objet d'un arrêté du
maire c'est à dire que aujourd'hui curé
hilson la messe à 8 heures le dimanche
pour dire dépêchez-vous alesi parce que
c'est leur personne et puis recommence à
11 heures commence à 18,6 à pas arrêter
quelqu'un fait un recours aux trimestres
hâtif
il est plus loin et perdu à mes pierre
le coq le gaulois qui sont là me code
alors pourquoi c'est pire encore c'est
que tu es bien sûr nous avons assuré le
col de chevaux dans toutes ces scènes
chantées par le maire notre agriculteur
à manger certainement son coach sait ce
qu'il en a fait mais parce qu'il a et
fin ça a été tellement compliqué qu'il
appelle une décision alors sais pas si
vous voyez une déçue en france qui était
favorable et jusqu'au conseil d'état et
la cour d'appel a pris quelques semaines
après une décision inverse on est on est
dans un endroit en perpétuelle
maintenant les yeux et lui faut mettre
que les coques sont interdits parce que
ça réveille les geôles mais voilà alors
dans les pme ça fait partie des décidé
d'aider des documents ni des documents
administratifs qui sont normalement de
la responsabilité du maire ou des
intercours enfin peu importe qui sont
systématiquement attaqués et à la fin
c'est le juge qui décide c'est ce n'est
plus du jeu mais il ya un mauvais
coucheur alors que les gens aient à
chevreuse parce qu'on entend les cloches
et pas celui du mobile dans le coq qui
chante ou non mais ça c'est là c'est
l'arrivée des citadins ce livre que mon
sentiment civile du bois
vient pas c'est pas les clashs justement
il reste dans quelques semaines voilà en
tant que maire à ce que des décisions
très difficiles en prendre en matière
justement de deux d'abus de 6 des
religieux peut-être d'immigration des
oeuvres toutes les heures est confronté
à ça sur l'alimentation sur les
attentive 51 camps d'été sur les
arrivées d'enfants en fait on serait
devant le juge d'instruction tous les
jours ci heureusement il n'y avait pas
un peu de compréhension sur notre
mission qui est d'assurer quelque part
le bien-être de chacun dans l'intérêt de
tous et c'est une difficulté majeure
et quand je vois les lois aujourd'hui on
vous aime dire ça va nous éloigner du
voile mais les voiles il faut les
régulières pour les chocs et marie-jo
que le vent arrive à faire avancer le
navire de notre france et bien
aujourd'hui on voit bien que on est en
train de réduire quelque part le pouvoir
des élus locaux de façon à éviter tous
ces problèmes durant une directive et
puis terminé et je veux dire aujourd'hui
nos habitants deviennent des usagers et
plus les habitants représentés par les
élus donc tout ça est un trait de faire
une modification de notre société qui
prend le pouvoir
point d'interrogation contribuables donc
vous voyez ils sont vraiment envisager
ça rejoint tout à fait une question
alors puisqu'on voit les difficultés qui
sont les vôtres quotidiennement
des élections municipales au moins deux
morts ce nom vous représentez ou pas mal
et ça c'est la question piège du moment
permettez-moi de réserver ma réponse au
plus tard on commence à y travailler oui
ils me fassent un travail d'équipé vous
savez on met le maire en avant c'est
souvent le maire qui en tête de pont à
chevreuse 6000 habitants c'est une
équipe de 29 personnes
on part à 29 on essaye d'arriver à 29
dans un temps iliad est un petit peu de
pertes en ligne mais moi ça n'a pas été
le cas donc là suis ravi c'est un
travail d'équipé
voilà on est effectivement déroutement
paix n'est pas confronté aux difficultés
qui sont les connivences une forte tous
les jours ne vous n'êtes pas de ceux qui
renoncent parce qu'il ya un certain mr
et qui renoncera aussi énormément de
source de réjouissance et de
effectivement voulons un atelier au
début c'est le monde dans lequel on voit
ce qu'on fait et on essaye de le faire
au mieux et je pensais en tout cas tous
les élus quelle que soit d'ailleurs les
les couleurs politiques tous les élus le
font avec un la plupart avec un
engagement et avec leur coeur on va dire
et il ya également de vraie source de
réjouissance et de pouvoir contribuer à
faire de notre commune mais bien sûr
mais bien sûr et puis et puis
franchement j'ai pas l'impression
j'ai pas l'impression je suis maire
depuis deux ans seulement donc voilà
j'ai pas l'impression que quand on
découvre la fonction en y arrivant tout
que je me bats je suis jeune mère je
savais dans quoi je m'engageais je ne
suis pas surprise
ce qui n'empêche pas de rouspéter un peu
on reste français donc ce serait
surprenant
voilà philippe brillault partant pour un
nouveau mandat
on parle du voile moi c'est avec mon âme
c'est avec mon âme parce que quand on
est maire faut avoir la foi
il faut avoir la foi dans les autres et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est
fondamental que nous puissions avoir la
fois de défendre et cette proximité qui
je le rappelle depuis 1982 avec la
gauche a entraîné la décentralisation la
décentralisation c'est extraordinaire ça
permet à tout habitant d'être
représentés et d'avoir une action
relayée auprès du gouvernement et je
pense d'ailleurs que depuis la règle du
cumul de mandats on a de plus en plus de
lois qui s'éloigne de la réalité du
terrain
parce que justement cette proximité
nécessaire et que souvent les gens qui
étaient sur le terrain ne sont plus
présents à l'assemblée sur nos vies
parce que si vous ne connaissez pas
toutes les les
le quotidien nous avons donc oui je
prépare effectivement avec une
quarantaine de personnes l'avenir pour
le chêne et rocquencourt
j'y contribue modestement comme vous le
savez est donc oui je ferai partie de
cette de ce challenge de la première
élection du maire du cher aux concours
alors vous savez que dans les dents les
élections qui se préparent les élections
municipales il ya certain nombre de gens
je soulève le risque de liste
communautariste on n'est pas loin du
premier sujet c'est notamment bruno
retailleau qui laisse un qui veut faire
un texte cdc d'éclairage est ici jeter
le voile mais voilà il veut jeter le
voile est ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il
faut interdire les lettres les listes
communautariste c'est au vert on va
essayer d'éclairer ce débat
[Musique]
alors justement est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas confrontés s'accompagnera d'une
communauté portugaise une comité
libanaise communauté bretonne donc des
communautés en a plein mais sur notre
liste
on a à peu près les représentants de
toutes les communautés donc je veux dire
une liste électorale c'est la
représentation de tout le monde et
chaque ville doit tenir compte de sa
composition
lorsqu'il était visé par un caillou
c'était plutôt l'union des musulmans
démocrates qui présentent des listes
dans un certain nombre de qui était
présenté aux européennes qui se
reprennent qu'il présente qui se
présente dans un certain nombre de
villes c'était plutôt ça qui était qui
était mon voisin qui voudrait répondre
justement nous aider ça m'amusait cissé
de l'île portugaise eu ce sens et peu de
gens inquiets de liste portugaise en
fait frais de communautariste portugal
va je pense que l'on peut dormir
tranquille il n'y a pas de l'ordre
public n'est pas menacé se régale avec
la communauté portugal 7 je pense
qu'avec les bretons ces problèmes
tranquillité non mais oui plus plus
sérieusement bas après si je pense que
c'est sous le sort de purement de lega
enfin je veux dire si effectivement il
est une loi une liste unie ce qui venait
dire que c'est des gens charmants qui
refuse de serrer la main aux femmes ou
de siéger au conseil municipal est des
femmes je pense que
le ministre de l'intérieur serait amené
à dire que c'est une liste qui n'a pas
l'aura de se présenter enfin j'ose
l'espérer voilà après tout et tout est
réglé et le moment si souvent
visionnaires et vous souvenez de romans
de houellebecq soumission dans les
lycées c'est tout à fait espère ne pas
prémonitoire en tout cas inquiétants
parce que c'est uniquement un problème
de droit c'est enfin j'ose espérer voyez
c'est bon il veut inscrire dans la
constitution le fait je m'éteins comme
le dit comme le nom de sa religion pour
se soustraire aux règles que ce nuage
posé le sait bien c'est déjà le cas
puisque c'est déjà une idée qu en fait
on fait en france on s'ingénie à
inventer des textes et on oublie les
principes généraux
c'est pour ça que j'ai une forme de de
déliquescence me semble-t-il de la
société de ce point de vue là c'est à
dire qu'on va de plus en plus vers le
particularisme y compris juridiques ont
fait des textes de plus en plus spéciaux
et ce faisant on détruit le principe
général
voilà donc que dire de plus c'est déjà
prévu l'état là sur le respect de
l'égalité des citoyens devant la loi
voilà donc l'égalité des citoyens devant
la loi est la loi et évidemment de la
république il n'y a qu'une loi celle de
la république et les citoyens sont égaux
devant la loi c'est déjà écrit donc il
suffit de l'appliquer en fait tout
simplement me semble-t-il
sauf que il ya des listes à mal et
l'islam aura remarqué évidemment le
parallèle qui a été fait avec les
démocrates-chrétiens donc on reprend la
même chose et on met les murs ils vont
aux chrétiens voilà je me prononcerai
pas là dessus je le déplore à titre
personnel parce que s'il ya un parti il
ya parti démocrate chrétien je suis loin
qu'ils veulent voilà que ces mutins je
suis un petit peu
naturellement si vous voulez méfiant on
va dire envers les religions en général
donc si vous voulez de ce point de vue
là je ne fais pas de différence
voilà il me semble que voilà à partir du
moment où on proclame dans un premier
article constitutionnel que la france
est une république laïque
il faut en tirer les conséquences tout
simplement
alors on va continuer avec les
municipales maison propose d'abord de
voir un sujet justement parce qu'il ya
des sondages qui montrent qu'une sorte
une majorité de français seraient vos
proches vos pauvres favorable une
alliance entre les républicains et le
rassemblement national ou des disques
sas droite c'est pas le cas dans les
yvelines où et ses noces un
rassemblement yvelinois je vous pose
regard des sujets qui consacrait qu on
en parle tout fait après ils n'ont pas
toutes et tous la même étiquette mais
font partie de la même grande famille
politique la droite en vue des
municipales en mars 2000 27 acres et
pierre que ces élus du département ont
signé la charte du rassemblement
yvelinois c'est la manifestation de
l'irrédentisme yvelines - c'est-à-dire
la volonté des élus yvelinois de refuser
les extrêmes
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite et
de se mettre d'accord sur un mode de
gestion sur des objectifs communs et on
veut leur apporter à travers le
rassemblement des chinois une espèce de
maisons communes dans lesquelles ils
peuvent se retrouver une maison commune
qui repose sur 7 piliers
parmi eux l'écologie la lutte contre
l'insécurité l'emploi ou encore les
politiques de solidarité c'est la fois
énorme une cohésion une harmonie autour
des élus et les yvelinois est également
un moyen de trouver les bonnes solutions
est à la fois financière et la foi d'
expertise pour les projets amenés futur
et en s'assurant effectivement de
certaines valeurs que nous partageons
parmi les signataires les républicains
mais aussi libre génération terrain udi
objectif avec cette charte proposer une
alternative en réveillant la droite et
le centre
en les amenant à se rassembler nous
souhaitons préparer et offrir une
alternative aux françaises et aux
français
je pense qu'il ya pas un maire de gauche
comme de droite en france nous fait pas
que la france gagne faut qu'on soit dans
cet esprit très largement au dessus des
postures idéologiques dogmatique et
politique qui exècre aujourd'hui les
français
ce document sera soumis aux candidats
des élections municipales qui pourront
s'ils le souhaitent bénéficier du label
rassemblement yvelinois alors on ne
reconnaît dans ce reportage pierre
bédier karl olive valérie pécresse
gérard larcher vous y étiez vous vous
adhérez à ce rassemblement et les mois
aussi les briauds moya rassemblement est
normal d'y contribuer mais nos listes ne
se limiteront pas uniquement au parti de
ce rassemblement je veux dire que dans
notre liste on a des gens aussi bien de
gauche dans marc chotteau apporte ce qui
est important c'est de rassembler toutes
les tendances de notre commune surtout
des personnes qui représentent donc
c'est bien mais je dirais une étiquette
politique ne fait pas une élection
municipale
une élection municipale c'est une équipe
qu'est ce qu'elles présentent
quel est son projet comment elle va
rassembler et voilà on a parlé aussi
dégagisme on a parlé de plein de choses
je ne sais absolument pas ce qui se
passera moi par exemple vous dites que
vous êtes une mère depuis peu de temps
ça fait 30 ans donc on me dira leurs
proches oba brio ça fait 30 ans ça
suffit on peut très bien dire ce qu on
peut les comprendre
donc ça veut dire que quelque part dans
l'équipe que dans lesquels je serai il
est important de pouvoir montrer aux
gens ce qu'on va faire avec qui et
comment c'est pas il renouveler aussi
voilà moi je suis pas tout seul au
volant comme tu l'as dit on est comme
nombreux
voilà donc le renouvellement bien
évidemment à plus de 80% on doit montrer
aussi qu'on est dans un nouveau monde
avec une population qui elle garde
toujours les mêmes principes ça veut
dire être dans un bon environnement pour
être heureux de pouvoir jouer au foot de
pouvoir faire du sport ou autre c'est
toutes ces fonctions que l'on a par
contre avec des formes peut-être un peu
différente
et donc c'est à nous de nous renouveler
c'est à nous de nous renouveler en tant
que personne et renouveler aussi avec
des personnes donc c'est pas les partis
politiques qui feront les communes et
les habitants avec le représentant
c'est pas une élection très politique
au sens habituel du terme on vote pas
forcément à droite ou à gauche dans les
élections municipales
surtout dans les communes comme le
concours sauf au lendemain des élections
qu'on ait pas d'effet que vous récupérez
pas voyez je savais que c'était le
meilleur je vous donne un exemple 89
quand j'ai été élu premier tour chirac
m'avait et président du rpr terminé
excommunié haute promises arrivent en
tête
j'ai eu un télégramme philippe pour
savais que tu étais le meilleur de notre
soutien à des sites web pas deuxième
corde mais c'est extra dire la dame et
saint louis donc ça c'est oui ils
viennent au secours après du succès mais
j'essaie d'y retrouver suspension dans
les cinq cents 500 clients ville le
maire est nécessairement un peu plus
éloigné de ses habitants parce qu'ils
sont plus nombreux parce que parce qu'on
les croise pas tous les jours ou parce
que voilà ce sera nécessairement que
pour les deuxième mi temps il ya deux
ans je effectivement dans ces élections
je pense que dans des sénatoriales
derrière nous
là les gens et lire les électeurs des
sénatoriales va pas dans les yvelines
puisque nos lieux de vie municipale
la demande est passée a pas longtemps
mais effectivement sur des communes de
notre taille vin généreux concours est
tellement plus grand que cheuvreux mais
on reste des communes de presque deux
provinces c'est un politique enfin je
veux dire on est on est peu à avoir un
engagement politique et c'est presque un
engagement politique plus personnel que
dans notre mandat d'élu mais on est on
est vraiment le mandat du quotidien
sûrement mon l'ensemble de mes
colistiers ont ni peut-être 5-6-7 avoir
un engagement politique clairement
affichée
et c'est même pas une question enfin ça
n'était pas jusqu'à jusqu'à il ya peu de
temps ce n'était pas une question qui se
posait on partait avec une équipe on
avait un projet on adhérait on avancer
ensemble pour la commune il est vrai
qu'avec le bouleversement du paysage
politique de ces derniers temps on nous
interroge un petit peu plus sur notre
positionnement est ce que vous
c'est simple souci dans marc cdc de
d'engranger quelques futurs grands
électeurs parce que c'est ce qui leur
manque pour cela augmenter leur force
c'est qu'ils en auront dans toutes les
listes
ouais dès la reprise le diesel vous
aurez des gens qui sont au format
nous en avons déjà vous bien sûr je veux
d abord genre va rassembler mais il ya
quand même ce sondage du figaro pour
dessein des sabres au figaro plus tôt
57% des sympathisants verts sont
favorables à un rapprochement avec le
rassemblement national
mais les sympathisants à l'air qui reste
c'est ce qu'ils sont pas partis chez en
marche
en gros donc forcément c'est un jeu
j'essaye de me dire que les centristes
de leers pas un petit peu malgré tout
voir un scellé leur en tout cas tous les
dons qu'ils produisent sur deux il ya
une droitisation d'élèves en ce qui me
concerne je réponds à titre tout à fait
personnel ça ne me satisfait pas et bon
j'ai pas quitter le navire en me disant
que si effectivement tout ce qu'on a
tendance plus modérée s'en vont on
n'arrivera pas soupçonner le problème
mais bon ça c'est ma vision personnelle
des choses mais moi je suis pas
tellement surprise parce
qu'effectivement le l'ensemble on l'a vu
dans les dernières échéances internes du
mouvement était le noyau dur qui reste
de l air est quand même un noyau
relativement radical on va dire je suis
pas tellement surprise ce résultat là je
pense que c'est dommage parce que
l'essentiel des électeurs de la droite
et du centre modéré sont partis chez en
marche mais à mon avis c'est peut-être
un peu plus simple de les inciter à
revenir que d'aller mendier chasser sur
les terres du front national en tout cas
moi je me retrouverais mort lorsqu'on
les demandes est déçu donc ils sont que
les gagnants par ailleurs qui est de
dire que tu es l'air deviendra et rennes
pas du tout je pense que si le prénom de
république ne rassemble pas tout le
monde dans les années qui viennent avec
des idées claires mais on a commencé par
le voile dans le libération ou autre
c'est l'ensemble des français qui
deviendront et rennes en réaction à
monsieur macron s'il n'y a pas des
choses fortes qui sont faites
voilà je crois que c'est plus cela la
vision des choses c'est pas l air ou
autre c'est tout simplement le pays s'il
n'y a pas des actions fortes sur ce
qu'attendent les gens on va voir les
retraites qu'est ce qui va se passer
pour les retraites
le pôle emploi
l'immigration la dette les finances
publiques tout ça est un vrai sujet moi
je voudrais pas être le président de la
république est en bonne santé mais il
faut que qui tienne compte un peu de
nous tous et je pense que les élus
locaux
au lendemain des municipales seront une
vraie force politique pour demain nombre
a vraiment que l'avenir politique qui se
fera par le terrain après les 1000 cc la
thèse offre de l'archer sens de la
proposition de l'archer ces diamants de
la conquérir le pouvoir en passant par
les territoires qui se tient prêt la
constitution venait à s'appliquer
il a dit qu'à lui le lendemain le
lendemain qui n'était pas candidat mais
si la constitution venait à s'appliquer
beaucoup et que je connais assez nord
c'est un petit rajout poste cette
interview c'est très régulièrement
entendus dans ce discours là son sens sa
parole préféré cette dire qu'il assure
la fonction de viager je pense que c'est
quelque chose après le regretté
président power de non pas nom de leur
idole cédant aux pressions de la
république 1 ne portait pas le nom non
seulement sur cette alliance arn
républicain c'est un serpent de mer fait
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent voilà
c'est la survie de la sueur et de la
droite elle peut passer comme ça de la
même façon que mitterrand avait s'était
allié avec les communistes pour gagner
là donc j'ai après je pense que de
chauffe-eau pas le gouvernail et sondage
là faut pas accorder trop d'importance à
ce sondage d'hier le nouveau patron de l
air vient d'être là d'être élu ça me
paraît pas du tout est train
le facho de base christian jacob voilà
sûrement des défauts mais j'aime aussi
des qualités je pense qu'il n'est pas
suspect d' aller frayer avec marine le
pen donc d'une baraque
voilà ça c'est quand même plutôt
rassurant et puis et puis après
effectivement je vous ai tout à fait
raison il ya quand même beaucoup de gens
le droit qui sont partis qui sont ravis
de la politique menée par emmanuel
macron je viens vous voilà après on
verra ce que christian jacob arrive à
faire du parti dit républicain et puis
voilà c'est aux pommes avec un quelqu'un
qui ne sera pas candidat aux
présidentielles
je pense que c'était la condition
sinequanone sinon franchement arrêtez je
pense à personne arrêtée du langage
la personne qui le dit maman wallonie on
se souvient de balladur dossier je ne
serai pas candidat je serais mal je sais
très bien que tu en as un petit mot
aucune valeur tout d'abord après c'est
l'occasion qui fait le larron
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il est un peu
prématuré de se lancer dans la
candidature à la présidentielle à mon
avis faut pas être trop présomptueux et
le chantier est suffisamment vaste pour
qu'on ait le temps d'y réfléchir ça ne
mangeait pas de pommes dire on n'ira pas
j'irai pas en 2022
non mais c'est vrai qu'elle sait
peut-être pas c'est peut-être pas non
plus le le personnalité qui a des
qualités qui n'est peut-être pas non
plus la stature
c'est l'occasion qui fait le larron
enfin aveu sidi saad emmanuel macron ici
même un josien un an et demi avant
l'élection présidentielle quand il a
commencé à pointer le bout du museau
allemande est elle autour de la table
sauf moi l'image de prouve en train de
dire ouais ça tiendra patins feu follet
il n'a pas la carrure il est trop jeune
il n'a pas d'appareil derrière lui il a
38 enfin bon on a vu ce que ça a donné
voilà il
didon donc voilà les jugements il n'a
pas la carrure
on verra après regan n'avait pas la
carrure pour être président des états
unis donald trump est pas la carrure
pour le président des états unis
des gens comparent la carrure avant il y
en a plein était un prêt et george bush
vous avez un nom je me disais simplement
que c'est pas tellement la droite qu'il
faut sauver ni la gauche c'est la
république oui je pense que c'est ça le
vrai projet et je pense que ceux qui
arriveront à faire revivre les principes
fondamentaux de la république en tant
que projet politique ont une chance de
faire adhérer tous les citoyens et
citoyennes qui se sont éparpillés un peu
partout mais m aujourd'hui d'avoir
déstabilisé par ce qu'il ya ça aussi
c'est de s'interroger pourquoi il
produit toutes les bases sont
déstabilisés donc est-ce que c'est lié à
des réformes qui sont pas suivis est-ce
que c'est lié à une volonté de
déstabilisation
quand je dis aujourd'hui les français
ont besoin qu'on pose un peu les choses
on a besoin de pas perdre tous nos
repères et aujourd'hui beaucoup de
repères sont perdus il faut recentrer
tout ça est ce que c'est une volonté
parler aussi des réformes sociétales
venons de tout malheur actuel de tout on
est perdu en tout il ya beaucoup trop de
deux mouvements avaient installé de
france mais a nié les inclure dans ces
même pas ça non je pense par exemple
regarder on a une réforme se terminerait
jugement là parce que c'est important on
est on veut sur l'environnement dax et
enfin faire d'eux des consignes sur les
emballages brutalement du jour au
lendemain on a mis dix ans à faire des
filières de récupération mon côté des
milliards sur le plastique sur tout ça
et en six mois il faudrait passer aux
consignes et supprimer tout ça en fait
oui des réformes et en ferons mais faut
le temps de le faire
il faut laisser du temps pour respirer
aux gens c'est comme puisque vous
parliez tout à l'heure un urgentiste un
malade car ils veulent tous les critères
qui sont mauvais ou les mettez la
perfusion propres en une heure tout soit
bon tout sera bon les rats morts vous
pouvez re attention qu'un pantin dire
que la république pourrait vaciller pour
une histoire de consignes de bouteilles
en verre et pézenas a fait ça
dick sur la méthode est simple et
ludique sur la méthode il ya des fous du
nord sur nos tableaux mais j'ai pas dis
noircir voici maintenant on est sur le
buzz que ça veut dire
on est sur le terrain moi je vous dis
aujourd'hui les gens ils ont besoin d'un
peu de respiration pour accompagner les
réformes indispensables mais il faut
nous laisser un petit peu de temps on
peut pas dire tout d'un coup on passe
deux voitures électriques n'en a besoin
d'un peu de temps et c'est là où on
manque de temps on est toujours dans
l'urgence et quelque part sur la loi de
thérapeutique c'est à dire que on fait
un truc parce que tout à coup il ya une
thérapeutique et je dis aujourd'hui
prenons un peu le temps d'écouter tout
le monde et prenons le temps de le
mettre en application
c'est ça n'ait pas l'impression que
c'est ce que fait le pouvoir aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression qu'un recul par
rapport à syracuse premier bien
conscient de provient d'un débat les
pions là qu'il faut pas aller trop vite
qu'il faut descendre sur les retraites
est serré il faut faire et se donner le
temps de le faire dans les retraites ce
pendant 20 ans seulement deux mots sur
deux personnalités qui ont été dans
l'actualité
un de vos confrères c'est vous dire
patrick balkany et est la première et
pelote qu'isabelle balkany condamné à de
la prison ferme
quel que soit ce qu'il ait fait ça quand
vous voyez un maire comme ça condamné à
de la prison ferme où j'ai honte pour
nos fonctions parce que quelque part il
ya trente-six mille mer et 36000 mer
sont pas comme balkany prodiges nés
c'est désespérant parce qu'on vit dans
un climat
je pense qu'ils qui se fait ressentir de
plus en plus de manière de plus en plus
pressante de suspicion on est élu donc
potentiellement on a trempé les doigts
dans le pot de confiture
je pense que tout le monde aimait
rivière l'assomption généralisée voilà
aussi que la justice veut faire de temps
en temps est-ce que c'est son rôle après
tout ce serait un exode parce que c'est
un début du conte des plus durement que
man 10 ans quand même pas les décisions
de justice et puis une fois qu'on a pris
ses précautions oratoires on peut on se
permettre de les commenter
est ce que le mandat de dépôt était
franchement nécessaire ou est ce qu'on
n'est pas comme tout à l'heure quand on
parlait du voile et
de sousse et de manifestations dues aux
petits parce qu'on n'est pas un petit
peu dans le spectacle est un petit peu
dans l'exagération qui fait qu'on
provoque des réactions qui sont très au
delà de ce qui serait logique et normal
d'avoir mais on ne commente pas les
décisions de cession ce oui c'est très
simple mais mais mes confrères se sont
déjà exprimés sur ce sujet a le mandat
de dépôt est une gesticulation politico
médiatique destinée à impressionner
lancer un message tous les praticiens du
droit savent très bien que les
conditions du mandat de dépôt à
l'audience n'était absolument pas
réunies fuite à l'étranger destruction
des preuves etc
oui il y avait du parti depuis longtemps
après sur la décision on a le même jeu
commentaire à faire je vois là je pense
que le dupond-moretti des visuels rôle
le paquebot vidéos tournées avocat en
défense d'intérêts particuliers et donc
on a tous les droits d'expression et de
voix la moindre des choses c'est
d'argumenter qui n'arrive à voir avec la
première c c'est dupont de ligonnes
n'était pas belle il a été ma mère
aimait mai mais il ya un maire des
yvelines qui est bien ennuyé je suppose
parce que voilà c'est mairie le maire de
givry ça servait un problème pour un ben
bernanke si vous avez qui est pris pour
un assassin en série a besoin
m à nous conforter mon propos c'est
scandaleux ce pauvre type
on a balancé son nom a balancé sa maison
rue balancer sa photo là aujourd'hui
c'est très bien en le masque masse
enfants leurs baskets voudrait qu'aucun
parfaitement alors ce cas des plus doués
du bien mais on peut décrire sur le banc
là on a balayé tout ça d'un revers de
main c'est vrai sa chance une certaine
manière c'est que ça n'a pas duré très
longtemps après qu'ils incarnent
finalement le guen innocente a donc
d'une certaine manière c'est moins grave
que d'autres personnes qu'est ce qu'on
avait tous envie que ce soit lui que ce
soit afin qu on retrouve dupont de
ligonnès se passe
les journalistes surtout qu'apparemment
beaucoup oui ça c'est sûr parce que j'ai
trouvé qu'avec un peu de mea culpa quand
même de la part des journalistes à part
certains qu'ils ont fait mais oui mais
c'est vraiment vraiment très longtemps
après et bien fait dans le parisien
et puis et puis le figaro s'est pas
trompé ils doivent d une salle aux
remises au final c'est seul journal à
voir chez ca en pages intérieures
dupont de ligonnès aurait été récusés
c2c de danton et journaliste expliquer
que finalement c'était la police
quand même qu'avec et c'est la faute de
ces la fausse et c'est sûr que là c'est
la faute de leurs sources say say say
exceptionnelles passées au verso c'est
la faute des zac aux mets donc en fait
que vous avez une mécanique une
mécanique qui s'habille comme direct de
gueule quoi qui était folle et qui
devient folle et qui dépasse qui fait
qu' aucun journal ne peut ne peut
refuser d'aller dans ce dans ce cours là
malheureusement j'ai celui de vivre une
mère et il me semble que les la police à
haut risque vraiment jamais en tout cas
le discours officiel des dés de la
police a toujours été compris du parquet
a toujours été on va voir moi j'ai pas
entendu de discours des autorités disant
que c'était lui
les écossais ou un petit peu mis le
bazar dans cette histoire parce que
c'était aussi un problème de l'europe
c'est que en écosse cinq points de
comparaison suffisent pour dire oui
c'est les même emprunté en france il en
faut 13,5 avec 5 il existe aussi assuré
la police française non c'est bien lui
donc là c'est vrai que direction la
vanille c'est la faute de l'europe merci
merci beaucoup à tous les cas merci
beaucoup à derry donc la prochaine volvo
reviendrait pour de dire si vraiment
vous représenterez définitive
merci vincent alessio merci philippe
brillault joconde où c'est que voilà
vous y travaillez déjà immersive sur
scène la jolie et banlieue ouest
on va demander de le dire merci à tous
[Musique]